رصد مخالفات ملاحقه سيارات الاسعاف او عدم
افساح الطريق لها لم يعد يدويا بل اصبح
اليا بدءا من اليوم بعد تركيب كاميرات في
مؤخره سيارات الاسعاف وكاميرات اخرى في
مقدمتها لرصد المخالفات اليا وارسالها الى
الانظمه المروريه لاصدار المخالفه ورد
الان بلاغ الى الهلال الاحمر وسنرافق هذه
السياره سياره الاسعاف لمشاهده اليه رصد
المخالفات الجديده واقعيا في شوارع الرياض
خلال دقائق فقط من انطلاق سياره الهلال
الاحمر لمباشره بلاغ تم رصد ما يقارب ثلاث
مخالفات لعدم افساح الطريق لسياره الاسعاف
المخالفات ايضا لملاحقه سياره الاسعاف
مستمره احنا عندنا طريقتين لرص المخالفات
الطريقه الاولى بالكاميرات المثبته في
مركبه الاسعاف كاميرا اماميه وكاميرا
خلفيه بضغط الزر يبدا التسجيل 20 ثانيه
عشر ثواني قبل ضغط الزر يتم حفظها وعشره
ثواني من بعدها بعدها يتم رفع المخالفه او
المقطع الى العمليات
لرصدها الطريقه الثانيه عن طريق نظام باشر
نظام المرور رسم المخالفات بالجوال يتم
تسجيل ثلاث صور الصوره الاولى
لوحه السياره الصوره الثانيه للسياره
كامله والصوره الثانيه للسياره بالمحيط
الحولها المخالفات هذه كذلك ترفع ولكن
ترصد مباشره فرقه عن المخالفات اللي مدمجه
في كابينه الاسعاف انه يتم فلترتها في
البدايه خلال واحده للهلال الاحمر وفي اقل
من نصف ساعه رصدت عشرات المخالفات
لملاحقه سياره الاسعاف هذا النظام الالي
الجديد لرصد المخالفات سيساهم كثيرا بالحد
من هذا النوع من المخالفات لرفع مستوى
السلامه المروريه في السعوديه من الرياض
نواف عزيز العربيه